Alhamdulillah.
Continuing in the book of prayer
regarding the times in which it is
impermissible to pray optional prayers.
The author now mentions a time that is
specific when it is prohibited to pray
an optional prayer and that is as the
author says.
It is likewise prohibited to pray
optional prayers after the prayer
has been announced. the for the
obligatory prayer has been announced. So
a person's in the masid
and the is called. Now it is obligatory
for a person to join the prayer. There
is no optional prayer during that time.
And this is exactly what the narration
says.
He says on the authority of Abi who
narrates that the prophet Sam
if the prayer has been announced and
established the has been called then
there is no valid prayer except for the
option
prayer.
He says in the footnote.
He then mentions what a very large
amount of scholars and and jurists
mention and that is that the question
now becomes if a person has already
started the optional prayer when the is
called what shall he do?
The majority of the scholars
are of the opinion
that
if he is unable
to finish his optional prayer before
and the obligatory prayer, then he is to
break his prayer and enter with the J.
And
another opinion of
the scholars of the fukah is that based
on the clear
the clarity of the narration and the
straightforward nature of the narration
he says
which which translates to no optional
prayer is valid
no prayer is valid after the is called
except for the obligatory one. This
means that a person is to break his
prayer immediately and join the
jama and this is the stronger of the two
opinions. If a person is in salah
sunnah,
you know, in a optional prayer, any
optional prayer
and the is called, he is to break his
prayer and enter into the obligatory
prayer immediately.
And the only prayer that is exempt
from this is an obligatory prayer,
right? Because the wording of the
narration if the is called then there is
no valid prayer except for the
obligatory one. If a person is in an
obligatory prayer let's say he's
traveling and he's joining prayers. He's
praying
for
rights to finish that prayer and then
join because it's an obligatory prayer.
He's doing what the narration is
commanded.
And this honestly is the stronger
opinion because we do not find any
narrations
where the prophet sallall.aii Wasam and
the companions are praying in the masjid
and there's other people making salah
not with the
just it was not a sight that you would
see
and so the companions understood that as
soon as the is called all other prayers
cease except for the obligatory one.
Have you ever
Well, you have. I'm positive you have.
But you come to the masid and when
people walk into the masid, the most
likely place if they're waiting for
salah for them to make their sunnah
salah is going to be where?
In the front row, right? Right here in
this row. Then the is called. They look
at the clock. They see there's only 20
30 seconds left. They Allahbar
and now they're praying right there.
Everybody is trying to make the row for
the salah, but he's praying. So, we
can't walk before him or behind him or
to the right or to the left and he's
just there and we all have to wait for
this person to finish his salah. This
never happened in the prophet's time
saiam
ever. Ever. Because when the is called
it is a it is an indicator that
everything else stops. Now how does a
person stop his prayer?
A lot of times you'll see people that
make
and they're standing.
They wish to leave that optional prayer.
they'll they'll make sleep. And you see
this a lot with people also that forget
to make wudoo
or break their wudoo during salah. They
leave the salah by making.
There is no narration that you will ever
find anywhere ever that the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam made
in any other position except for the
sitting position after
or in salah janaza
in the janaza prayer. Yes, you make
while you're standing. That's the only
in instance an exception.
It would be no different than a person
reciting fatud.
It would be no different than making
sujud before aur. It would be no
different than sitting in the standing
position or standing in the sitting
position. Tim's place is after
in order to end the prayer at its point.
If a person leaves the prayer before
that point, they just leave. That's it.
There's no
and this is something common
you'll find. There is no clear evidence
for this. And so if a person is praying
and they must leave the salah for some
reason, they just leave. And immediately
upon intending to leave the prayer, your
prayer is broken. Anyways, the mere
intention to leave the prayer already
ends the prayer without a person doing
any of this other fancy,
right? And I say this is it had not it
had from the scholars it had from the
common man right how many of us have
seen this before right we've seen this a
lot maybe even we do it but if you think
back where did I get this from well we
saw other other people doing it and we
assumed that that was the correct way to
do it right
and So
if a person is in salah and the is
called
in the correct opinion they are to leave
the prayer immediately and join the
salah
and at most the scholars agree
that it's not permissible to continue
praying the optional prayer and miss
this rur of the obligatory prayer.
So we have two instances.
A person leaves immediately upon the is
call. This is the correct opinion.
Second, a person stays in salah
to finish but he can finish before.
This is the absolute most than any
scholar has mentioned.
Number three, a person finishes his
optional prayer even if he misses
one or two raqa of the obligatory
prayer. The scholars have all agreed
this is incorrect.
We understand these three scenarios.
And
if if you were to hear this statement of
the prophet Sam
If the prayer the has been called
then there is no prayer except for the
obligatory one. What would you
understand from that? Would you
understand from that to keep praying as
long as you don't miss?
because this is using evidences from
elsewhere that don't belong there. This
is why we mentioned that
the
apparent face value of the narration
is leave salah. You leave it because the
prayer is no longer is no longer
necessary. Is it obligatory for a person
to be in salah?
And this brings us to an important
point. A point that is very very
commonly misunderstood.
How many of us have seen or ourselves
have done
that the salah is going on
and we let's say are on a phone call or
sitting and waiting and you see this a
lot during
in Ramadan
that a person will sit and watch the
prayer until the imam goes into and then
they join. Do you know what I'm talking
about? Have we seen this before? You see
this a lot. Why do I say and tell her we
cuz people get a little tired, right? So
they will sit and watch the prayer and
listen to the recitation and watch the
imam until he reaches. Then they get up
and join the prayer. It's kind of a
a hack, right? a a cheat
code, right? The scholars agree this
salah is invalid.
The scholars agree this salah is
invalid.
Why?
Because the prophet Sam
said
he said whoever catches the of a prayer
has caught the prayer. Correct.
This narration does not apply to someone
who purposely
avoids praying part of the prayer. This
narration is speaking to someone who's
late, something that is out of his
control. He's making woo. He's on his
way to the masid and despite his best
efforts, he's missed a portion of the
beginning of the prayer. But those parts
that you deliberately missed in salah,
the recitation of fat, standing for the
recitation
of al fat and elsewhere, saying Allah
abar to go into these are pillars
and you cannot miss them purposely
because a pillar by its very definition
is that if a person misses it, the
prayer is invalid. This is an invalid
prayer and a lot of people do this
invalidating their prayer not even
knowing that they are doing this. If a
person deliberately leaves off a portion
of the salah with the im then this will
nullify the person's prayer
rather the a person may say well I'm
tired during what shall I do join the
prayer while you're sitting sit
you will get half the reward for sitting
that you will for standing and the
optional prayer it's permissible to sit
in In the standing part, you just
receive half the reward. If you're
tired, sit in the row and start your
salah. Join the salah immediately.
There's no instance in which you are
supposed to be praying with the j and
you're just sitting watching the j be
made as as you breeze out in the
corner waiting for your time to to
jump in. You ever see the
kids playing jump rope and they wait
then they jump into the jump rope? This
is this is not that situation. If you
are joining the prayer you have to join
as immediately as possible. And we
will have an entire section in the book
regarding this issue which we'll discuss
later on inshallah.
[Silence]
What is